في الوقت الحالي ، يقول فريق عمل البيت الأبيض المعني بفيروس كورونا
إن أكثر من نصفنا نحن
البالغين حصلوا على حقنة واحدة على الأقل من 19
، واليوم يمكن أن تزيد التوصية الرئيسية
من وتيرة التطعيمات ، حيث
إن التصويت 10 لصالح
أربعة معارضين وامتناع واحد عن التصويت.
يوصى باستخدام لقاح covey للأشخاص الذين تقل
أعمارهم عن 18 عامًا أو أكبر في
مجتمع الولايات
المتحدة من لقاح cova 19 الذي يحتوي على جرعة واحدة من جونسون وجونسون
عند التوقف مؤقتًا
بعد الإبلاغ عن حالات جلطات دموية نادرة ،
ولكن أوصت لجنة استشارية من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
للعودة إلى اللقاح  استخدم ، أعتقد أن
هناك الكثير من
الأشخاص المهتمين بلقاح JJ حتى الآن
في
الولايات المتحدة ، يعرف مركز السيطرة على الأمراض أن 15 امرأة
طورت جلطات دموية مرتبطة باللقاح
وتوفيت ثلاث منهن أثناء
التجربة السريرية التي عاشها رجل واحد أيضًا
الجلطات وعولجت الحوادث ، إنه حدث
نادر جدًا
أن تكون حوالي 10 إلى 15 حالة
لكل مليون من السكان
على الجمهور الأمريكي  إدراك
أن هناك خطرًا يتمثل في أنه
خطر نادر للغاية ،
لكن هذا فيروس شائع
وفيروس تسبب
في الكثير من الضرر الذي يمكن منعه عن طريق
اللقاح ، سيتعين على كل من cdc
و fda الموافقة على
توصية اللجنة التي
تزن  الخطر المحتمل من اللقطة
مع خطر الإصابة
بفيروس كورونا
في واشنطن أبلغتني إيزابيل روساليس